- So I got this guy's
number the other night
And I don't know if I should wait
for him to call me or I should call him
- This is totally, pretty basic stuff.
There's a scientific formula for this
- Max, there's no science
to this sort of thing.
You just have to feel it!
Definitely not now.
But soon. Don't wait too long
Nope. No dude!
Just look inside yourself!
- The universe will give me a sign.
Woah!
Woah! Did you see that man?
- See what?
Right there! Right outside our window!
There's a crazy looking guy
- Ok so if the guy is G, and time is X
then you just divide the number of hours..
- No, no, no
We need to take into consideration
We both have each others' numbers
and that we met on a Sunday
which is the start of a work week..
Wait!
- Woah, it's my phone!
What's my phone doing out here?
(startled noise)
Who are you?
You're my spirit guide, aren't you?
How do I know when to call her?
- (goofy laugh)
- I've got her number right here
- Where'd he go?
- (inaudible yell)
- For the past five weeks
The fifth obituary in the LA Times
in 2015 has started
with the fifth letter in the alphabet, E.
Look at this crossword puzzle
The place five down, five across
with all E's.
- Hold on this is getting out of hand.
- How many fingers on your hand?
Five!
- Where are you?
- Hello!
- How do you keep doing that?
Are you saying bananas bruise quickly?
That I should call while the time is ripe?
Oh! Ow!
What?
Where did you go?
(inaudible yell)
- Same white van has
driven by three times now
They're onto us
Quick turn the phones off
We need to turn both of our phones off!
- Then how will you know
if he is calling you?
- Damnit! You're right!
It's not just an equation for when to call
it's connected to everything!
It's bad.. It's really bad.
- I need to call someone for you.
I legitimately think that you might be
losing your mind.
- What does it mean?
Why is it a banana?
Why did I follow you here?
When should I call?
(inaudible yell)
- Wait! I'll just call him.
Yeah. Let's do this in
15, I'll just call him.
- What the...?
Oh! I'll just call her!
I'll just call her.
Oh she's calling me!
Hello? Hey!
- Hey!
- I was literally just about to call you
and, I would like to
go to dinner with you.
Yeah. What time is good for you?
(rock music)
- What about five?
- Ok, yeah that seems a little early
but yeah, that's fine! Five is great.
Awesome! Weird day..
- Banana!